so i get a lot of emails about how do i  stay motivated hungry  driven well let me tell you something  most days in life when i wake up i'm not  motivated hungry or driven  i commit to myself the best person  myself  what most of us are looking for is a  special  feeling of oh i feel great this morning  i'm gonna get out of bed and get a quick  five miles in or go to the gym  if you're looking for that feeling let  me tell you what thing ain't gonna come  you have to learn to do when you don't  wanna do it  learn to bring that savage mentality out  of yourself the animalistic [ __ ]  you think a savage gift about how he  feels or how she feels  they just do it learn to be your best  self when you're least motivated  stop looking for a feeling to control  what goes on in your life